that's a
six
that's an r
that's an h
and if you didn't know any better you
might think i'm getting an eye exam but
i'm actually demonstrating my own
combination of pattern recognition and
feature recognition in performing a
little optical character recognition
or simply known as o
c
r
fortunately this isn't something we
really need to do the hard way anymore
but before ocr it was it was fairly
common for a person to sit there
manually typing out the contents of page
after page after page
look some of the earliest work in ocr
was pioneered by ray kurzweil yes that
ray kurzweil who develops technology in
the early 1970s capable of recognizing
printed text in virtually
any
font
from there ray and his team developed
speech synthesis technology capable of
reading printed text out loud so the
next time your gps lets you know there's
a left turn coming up make sure to say
thanks to kurzweil computer products
incorporated
ocr has come a long way since then in
both speed and accuracy and the ability
to automate complex document processing
workflows means formatted information
can retain its structure after being
scanned and as you can imagine that's a
huge benefit for industries dealing with
forms and printed documents but
how does it work
well before we get down to decoding this
and decoding that
well
let's talk about how an ocr program
first needs to analyze the structure of
the document image it needs to do things
like identify the area of text
it needs to do things like figure out
the lines of text the spacing between
the words and all sorts of other
document elements and once it's loaded
in the characters they're rendered to a
high contrast thing called a
bitmap
and from there they can be processed by
any number of algorithms speaking of
which the most common algorithm is known
as
pattern
recognition that's what i was doing
right at the start
now pattern recognition involves first
training a computer with a very large
set of known characters just like
imagine a powerpoint that's just like
eight million slides of the letter l all
different possible representations of it
keep that in mind next time you're about
to complain about a boring status call
now with a learned understanding of what
pretty much any imaginable variation of
every character may look like it's just
a matter of comparing the identified
character and then finding the closest
matching one
another common algorithm is known as
feature analysis
and feature analysis is a little bit
different
from pattern recognition
it relies on the characteristics of each
individual character like how many lines
it has whether it has curved lines if
any of those lines intersect so let's
say that it sees two straight diagonal
lines something like
these guys here
so if it sees that they come together at
the top there's a high probability here
that we're looking at either letter a or
a letter w
so it will check to see if there's a
line connecting the diagonal lines
looks like an a
or two more lines connecting to those
first two lines at the
that
bottom
recognize a w
so where pattern analysis relies on lots
and lots of examples to train a model
the big boring power point this is more
rule-based and it requires a deeper
understanding of those characters on the
part of the developer but in theory it
should be able to handle new fonts
without needing to be retrained
suffice to say
ocr continues to be enhanced year after
year some early ocr needed to be
manually guided and corrected sometimes
performing only slightly faster than a
person at a keyboard but today's ocr can
find and read a license plate even when
it's traveling on a vehicle under a toll
bridge at like 65 miles per
hour perhaps even faster
ocr combined with ai has proved to be a
winning combination it's what helps tell
us our o's
from our
zeros
it tells us our ais from our als it
helps us distinguish our lols from our
101s
by analyzing broader contextual and
linguistic patterns ai is able to
correct some mistakes that may slip
through the cracks from ocr performed at
a purely character by character level
and don't just think books and forms the
need to turn printed characters into
ascii characters will only accelerate
the traveler using an augmented reality
app overseas to understand store signs
the passengers in a self-driving car
that'll be reliant on ocr and ai's
ability to handle letters from things
like dark blurry video confusing
perspectives with like snow
faded paint one sign in front of another
where
we're about to see this technology taken
in some amazing new directions
and all it asks in return is that we
stop using comic sans
it's seen every font in the entire
universe trillions of times over and it
says that's the worst one and the sooner
we take care of that the sooner we can
get those self-driving cars
seems like a pretty fair trade to me
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe
thanks for watching